In this lecture, we focus most of our attention on air pollution
because that is, by far, the most important way in which the energy
system impacts human health today.
I&#39;m going to talk you about some of the most important airborne pollutants--
the so-called criteria air pollutants as defined by the US Environmental
Protection Agency.
We can divide the list into two categories: direct pollutants
and secondary pollutants.
Lead, nitrogen oxides or NOx, sulfur dioxide or SOx, and carbon monoxide
are direct pollutants, in that they are emitted directly
from industrial activities-- primarily, the combustion of fossil fuels.
Ozone is a secondary air pollutant.
There is no significant direct emission of ozone.
Instead, ozone is formed in the atmosphere when
various other pollutants-- most importantly NOx--
react in the presence of sunlight.
Particulate matter falls into both categories.
Some particulate matter is emitted directly.
Think of the visible smoke one sees from a diesel truck.
But other particulate matter forms in the atmosphere from chemical reactions,
such as those involving NOx and SOx.
Let&#39;s start with the direct pollutants.
Lead used to be added to gasoline to improve combustion
in automotive engines.
It reduced preignition of the air-fuel mixture, called &quot;knock&quot;.
However, lead is a potent neurotoxin.
Lead emissions from gasoline reduced the IQ of children growing up
in polluted cities.
This was no minor effect.
Lead levels were high enough in the 1970s
to reduce the average IQ of Americans who grew up then by five points.
Lead pollution has been greatly reduced due to stringent regulations that
banned its use in gasoline and restricted
use elsewhere across the economy.
The average lead levels in Americans&#39; blood
has gone down by more than a factor of 10.
This is one of the many examples where environmental regulations have greatly
improved human welfare and have had a positive economic benefit that
greatly exceeded the direct cost of imposing the regulation.